foreign
how is a camel bladder a competitive
advantage
and so because people go so what so why
so you you don't go to the bathroom I
mean I went to a signing not long ago
and I got there at seven and I signed
from seven in the morning to midnight
and I didn't move from the desk where I
was signing from now again other human
beings had to eat and go to the bathroom
so I go you better have two teams then
you're gonna have to rotate them
let me just sort of quickly get out of
the way first how you cannot go to the
bathroom for 17 hours it's really sort
of easy stuff if you don't put anything
into your top hole nothing comes out of
any of the bottom holes right just it's
just basic so I don't eat and I don't
drink
that's a whole nother conversation but
like they're going what what how do you
do that that's another conversation but
if you don't put anything nothing in
nothing out simple easy and I know this
to be scientifically true because I've
used it to my advantage now because I
have a camel bladder two things have
happened in my career that I think have
been advantageous one
everybody when I go to the conventions
would have to go and take a lunch break
why because they're hungry
they're hungry like my wife would tell
you I have never uttered those words I'm
hungry I eat because science says I need
to my body needs fuel so I put it in not
because I'm hungry because I have to
it's an essential ingredient food
so I do it but I cannot last you if
you've got to go away so people would
take off at conventions and go away for
lunch or bathroom breaks or whatever
guess who didn't
me and here's why that matters because
there's people in line and if you've got
at the time of our popularity when they
used to open it up you'd have at times
I'm telling you literally thousands of
people in line waiting for your
autograph first off in good conscience I
can't have somebody waiting in line for
two hours three hours and then look at
them and say cut I'm going for an hour
and a half lunch break and the kids
going what I've already been in line for
three hours like I can't do it I can't
look at somebody in the eye I won't do
it so I said no I'll just figure out how
to not do this thing that most humans do
so and here's where the upside is is
that when all my peers have gone to
lunch then people are waiting in line
and then they're just sitting there
going well that guy's still signing
what's his name Todd Tom Tim whatever
what's he do Spiderman well I like comic
books I know Spider-Man and guess what
happens Tim they'd get in your line they
don't care really at that point about
you they just go he's signing the line's
moving I'll get in his line and then
they come up you've got 20 seconds
you've become as gracious as you can to
them and maybe you peel off and you've
got a new couple fans and all of a
sudden it's like you know I only collect
X-Men but you know that Todd was a
gentleman and he was very nice and he
smiled at me he was very kind you know
what maybe I'll go buy one of his
Spider-Man books or you know in the
future respond books and so that's it
good right I'll always be nice to
anybody no matter who they are number
two on the business end and this one is
sadly even easier and it's just pathetic
at times
I live in Phoenix Arizona and Phoenix
Arizona can be 110 degrees let me tell
you I'm like a cockroach I don't care
what the weather is I'll survive don't
worry about me I'm good but here's what
I know about other people they have
comfort zones and so whenever I was in
some big legal dispute or contract
dispute I would say especially the
people in L.A I go you fly them to me
you fly them to me now this is just the
Art of War so my desk is facing a big
giant glass window right and I know when
the sun comes down that window now when
usually when I'm in my room I bring down
the drapes and I put up the AC and I'm
comfortable but when the enemy is coming
I.E the people I've got to negotiate
with come right I make sure that the
blinds are up and that I turn the air
conditioning so that it's actually
stuffy in that room because why I can
endure it I've done it plenty of times
and then they always come dressed in a
three-piece suit wrong move guys wrong
move and then they come in and they come
into the room and I close the door and I
know it's going to get stuffy and then I
put a giant pitcher of water in front of
them and then I uttered the words
guys this has been going on far far too
long here's the deal
we're not leaving this room until we
settle every single outstanding point
and during those conversations
they either pour their own water
on a constant basis because they've got
their three-piece wool suit on I've got
my t-shirt and my and I'm in my my Nike
shorts
and I can just see them getting hotter
and hotter and hotter and they keep
having to get more and more water and at
some point nature calls and then we get
down to the last one and they go I go
I'm not moving on on point ten I'm not
moving it's a deal break if I don't get
it this whole deal and you know how many
times I've had people in my room go fine
this is how it works it goes like this
time fine you can have point 10 are
redone yes are we done yes where's your
bathroom the very next thing is where's
your mask because I think in my mind
that they literally came in on the 10th
point because they couldn't hold it
anymore and if they could have held it
they could have argued longer with me
and perhaps I might have conceded or we
could have compromised on that point but
their bladder cost them too bad how sad
you find your advantages wherever you
can get them
oh McFarland the Barbarian what a Savage
nice work